[Musique]
bienvenue dans cet entretien politique
avec jean-noël barrot qui est député de
la 2e circonscription des yvelines vice
président de la commission des finances
à l'assemblée nationale et secrétaire
général du modem avec lui on va essayer
de dresser le bilan de la situation
économique en france et dans les
yvelines
et puis de l'explicité les perspectives
de croissance pour 2021 bonjour jean
noël barrot alors on a les chiffres le
recul de pib cette année sera de 9 1%
c'est moins pire que ce qui était prévu
grâce au rebond du troisième trimestre
mais concrètement ce recul du pib ça se
traduit comment ça se traduit par des
mesures de soutien qui sont venus
absorber une grande partie de ce choc de
ceux de cette baisse de la richesse que
produit notre pays donc c'est ce sont
nos nos finances publiques qui absorbe
une partie du choc mais ce qui est
devant nous les est évidemment
inquiétant et il faut y être extrêmement
attentif
nous avons des commerçants des
professionnels de l'hôtellerie cafés
restauration des professionnels tourisme
des professionnels de la culture qui ont
fait pour certains une année presque
blanche et qui vont donc aborder 2021
avec je dirais dès que des capacités
d'investissement des capacités de
recrutement qui sont très affaiblis et
puis nous avons aussi et notamment dans
les yvelines
des secteurs qui je pense à
l'aéronautique en particulier qui non
seulement auront subi jeudi rennes les
confinements comme les autres secteurs
de l'économie mais qui en plus ont des
perspectives à deux trois quatre ans
qu'ils sont déprimés et donc ces groupes
ces groupes de l'aéronautique notamment
vont être vraisemblablement amenée ils
ont déjà commencé à prendre des
décisions difficiles en matière d'emploi
pour faciliter les transitions
inévitable vert
des nouveaux marchés qui sont un peu
plus porteurs de croissance donc en
résumé c'est un choc qui a été largement
absorbés par les dispositifs massif de
soutien qui ont été mises en oeuvre
mais c'est aussi des points de vigilance
important sur ce qui est devant nous
hier la fragilité dans lesquels dans
laquelle cette crise aura laissé un
certain nombre d'entreprises et
notamment dans les yvelines
vous parlez de l'industrie aéronautique
on pourrait ajouter l'industrie
automobile qui est très présente sur ce
territoire il ya un certain nombre
d'économistes et disent que plutôt que
d'aider ces entreprises il faudrait
mieux faire porter l'effort sur la
formation des salariés
qu'en pensez vous alors c'est c'est une
très bonne question et c'est un point
absolument fondamental il va venir un
moment où nous allons devoir
progressivement sortir des dispositifs
de soutien qui ont été conçus pour pour
je dirais répondre très largement et de
la manière la moins discriminante
possible aux besoins des entreprises
mais on va devoir un moment donné en
sortir et il faut qu'à ce moment-là nous
puissions convertir ces dispositifs de
soutien en des dispositifs
d'accompagnement de ces transitions vous
parler de la formation professionnelle
il ya potentiellement d'autres d'autres
vecteurs de de transition de conversion
il ya des entreprises qui vont devoir
réorienter leurs activités pour rester
profitable pour rester rentables et et
donc il sera très important qu'en
complément des des mesures du plan de
relance un qui va c'est qu'ils vont
s'étaler pendant les deux prochaines
années qu'on puisse être très attentif à
à tous ces secteurs toutes ces
entreprises et par conséquence tous ces
territoires qui vont devoir se
réinventer pour pouvoir rebondir
rapidement
on va passer maintenant aux perspectives
alors on connaît des chiffres la
croissance prévue pour 2021 selon le cd
se serait de 6,1 pour cent c'est plus
d'ailleurs que l'allemagne qui à 2,8
même si l'allemagne évidemment avait
moins chuté
qu'est ce qui explique ces bonnes
perspectives
et est-ce qu'on peut y croire oui je
crois qu'on peut y croire pour pour deux
raisons ce qu'il explique en partie ses
perspectives c'est que
la chute est tellement importante en
2020 conques il ya un phénomène presque
mathématique de rebond c'est à dire que
à mesure que l'économie va retrouver son
régime de croisière
on voit par rapport au creux de 2020
observé des taux de croissance
importants
mais au-delà de ça je crois que et sans
méconnaître un délai fragilité que j'ai
évoqués en réponse à votre première
question je crois qu'il ya il ya un
motif d'espoir qui résident dans le jeu
d'hier est là la probabilité croissante
de jour en jour qu'à l'horizon de la fin
de l'année 2000 21 dans les pays de l'
ocde notamment ils puissent on puisse
disposer de vaccins et des campagnes de
vaccination ait pu avoir lieu
la france a mis en place un plan de
relance de 100 milliards d'euros dont 40
viennent de l'europe
quel est le meilleur usage qu'on peut
t'on faire l'écouté il ya un axe qui est
évidemment prioritaire c'est celui de la
transition écologique qui va faire
l'objet de plusieurs dispositifs ceux
qui sont déjà mises en oeuvre c'est ou
en tout cas pour lesquels les appels à
projets ont d'ores et déjà été lancée
c'est la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments publics les collectivités vont
pouvoir elles aussi bénéficier de
soutien très important pour la
rénovation de leurs bâtiments et
l'industrie c'est à dire les entreprises
pourront elles aussi émarger sur des
dispositifs de subvention à la
décarbonation donc ça c'est évidemment
la kz prioritaire il ya aussi d'autres
d'autres axes qui sont visés par ce plan
de relance
la numérisation et la
réindustrialisation ou la relocalisation
d'un certain nombre d'activités et donc
là il ya certain nombre de dispositifs
qui sont accessibles aux entreprises et
d'ailleurs où loge en josas
une entreprise a été lauréate de l'un de
ses premiers appels à projets et cela a
été annoncé la semaine dernière et et
ses dispositifs vont permettre de
renforcer notre tissu industriel
qui s'était très largement dégradée même
si depuis quelques années la chute qui
semblait irrémédiable de l'emploi
industriel s'était ralentie donc voilà
la transition écologique
la relocalisation et puis la
digitalisation et ça ça concerne
évidemment tout le spectre de la grande
entreprise industrielle
jusqu aux commerçants puisque vous savez
qu'on a mis en place un certain nombre
d' aide des aides de l'état mais aussi
des collectivités de la région ile de
france pour accompagner les commerçants
dans leur digitalisation alors parlons
concrètement de ce plan de relance
comment se décident les investissements
et qui le fait notamment dans ce
département il yal architecture générale
et puis il ya là il ya la mise en oeuvre
et donc selon les dispositifs le
l'interlocuteur des collectivités des
entreprises des associations ou même des
biens sur des françaises et des français
qui veulent rénover énergétiquement lors
leur logement se seront soit les
services de l'état la préfecture du
département la préfecture de région et
en particulier pour les dispositifs
collectivités soient les opérateurs de
l'état que ce soit la même pour tout ce
qui concerne la transition écologique
que ce soit la bpi la banque publique
d'investissement pour un certain nombre
d' aides aux entreprises qui instruiront
les dossiers sur le site du ministère de
l'économie et des finances vous
trouverez une une plateforme très bien
faite qui en fonction de la nature de
votre activité et de votre organisation
vous orientera vers l'interlocuteur
adéquat reste un dernier problème c'est
la dette qui s'accroît est ce que le
quoi qu'il en coûte doit rester la règle
jean-noël barrot
je crois que il serait déraisonnable de
vouloir trop vite resserrer la ceinture
pour pour si nous voulons sortir au plus
vite de cette crise ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que aujourd'hui la france n'a
aucune difficulté comme les grands pays
européens à emprunter sur les marchés
pourquoi parce que il y a dans le monde
en raison
deux dynamiques structurelles 1 2 une
grande quantité d'epargne qui provient
notamment des pays en développement avec
des classes moyennes qui se développe et
qui épargne pour leur retraite et cette
épargne cherchent des placements sûrs et
les placements les plus sûrs que l'on
trouve à travers la planète
ce sont les les dettes souveraines de
pays comme la france comme les
etats-unis qui disposent de moyens pour
lever l'impôt et rembourser à terme
cette dette là donc il ya beaucoup plus
de gens qui veulent de nous prêter que
d'argent que nous voulons emprunter et
pour vous donner une illustration de ce
phénomène l'année 2020 aura été l'année
où la dette publique de la france aura
augmenté de 20 points de pib
d'accord et pour autant la charge
d'intérêts payés par la france à ses
créanciers aura baissé dans le même
temps d'accord donc on est vraiment dans
une situation où on s'est beaucoup
endetté on s'est endetté comme les
autres pays européens d'ailleurs mais on
partait d'un niveau plus élevé
malheureusement on s'est beaucoup
endetté mais paradoxalement parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d' épargne qui cherchent à
se placer sur les titres de la dette
française la charge de la dette abaissée
alors ce qui est essentiel plutôt que de
resserrer la ceinture c'est de nous
assurer que les dépenses publiques qui
sont mises en oeuvre
grâce à cet endettement elles soient
utilisés à bon escient
qu'elles soient utilisées notamment de
façon ponctuelle pour répondre à la
crise plutôt que de créer peut-être des
dépenses qui serait définitive ou ou
pérenne et que nous puissions grâce à
ces dépenses retrouver une dynamique de
croissance qui nous permettent à terme
vient de faire baisser notre niveau
d'endettement parce que le niveau
d'endettement il n'est pas un problème
aujourd'hui mais il pourrait à terme
devenir donc il faudra faire baisser ce
niveau d'endettement qui est aujourd'hui
d'environ 120 % du pib
merci beaucoup jean noël barrot se
retrouve très prochainement pour un
nouvel entretien politique sur tv 78
[Musique]